so so for them to construde American
Patriots as some kind of coded
incitement is absolutely derangement
type thinking that is nonsensical that
is as you said insane these people are
absolutely crazy they lost their marbles
they lost the plot they don't know
what's going on here and and they will
think of any reason just to punish any
kind of political speech that they don't
like because it triggers them and it
activates this kind of fight-or-flight
instincts in them that scares the crap
out of them it's a ball drop by
administration at Twitter because you're
you get as an administrator I know this
firsthand doing it at mines you get the
you face with the decision I have to do
what either what I want to happen or
what is right and often what you want is
not what is right so you have to do
what's right and you don't get what you
want out of it but here's my question
because I genuinely understand like how
is there a difference between between
the two you know in my perspective
I don't want anything from any of these
people